précise sonia rolland
sonia rolland bonsoir alors laisse lui a
fait le loft pour accélérer sa carrière
de deux chanteuses vous vous êtes
devenue miss france pour accélérer votre
carrière de comédienne et dans les deux
cas ça a marché
ça a marché ben ça marche j'espère ça
marchera toujours alors elodie gossuin
elle l a fait mieux elle a fait à la
fois miss france est à la fois la
téléréalité voulait pas faire de télé
réalité non j'ai déjà refusé
j'ai refusé choix nice people ou nice
people un ouais ouais pourquoi pourquoi
faire de la peine madame de fontenay
non non non pour ne pas me faire de la
peine et peut-être à mes parents aussi
quoi n'intéresse pas en tous les cas
madame de fontenay pas du tout contente
elle a dit c'est une provocation
inacceptable envers des millions de
français qui vivent dans la pauvreté
sans être payés des millions en
contrepartie c'est-à-dire qu'elle est
les foals oui surtout les agriculteurs
et puis les gens qui habitent en
province dans des fermes on a
l'impression qu'on les prend vraiment
pour ils n'ont pas de toilettes pas
salle de bains enfin arrêter quoi ça
vous choque sonia vos poèmes ça me
choque parce que je viens de la france
profonde aussi bon à part ça j'ai vécu
au rwanda j'ai vu que vous me dit mais
j'ai vécu aussi en bourgogne un reee
cela m'emmerde de voir ce à quoi merde
c'est vrai quand on dit toujours qu'on
le fait pour des associations mais c'est
vrai que ça justifie pas tout madame de
fontenay a dit à quand un film
pornographique au profit de la croix
rouge
pas con way back on pas qu'on geneviève
1 1 et les contours de votre série sur
m6 j'aime bien vrai il ya participé à
nos bas
rien à dire mais c'est comme ça que j'ai
commencé ma carrière et ça arrive il
m'est arrivé un jour de faire un cadavre
à la morgue à la morgue de l'hôpital
saint-antoine pour un vieux maigret et
soulever le rat est dit on pourra dire
au parquet qui n'a pas souffert citez
moi tu l'as fait pour l'argent à
l'époque sur quatre en tous les cas donc
léa parker c'est sur m6 le dimanche à
18h50 ça marche bien c'est l'histoire
d'un agent double en fait vous êtes
archiviste au ministère de l'intérieur
mais la vérité c'est que vous êtes le
capitaine d'une cellule ultra secrète de
la police nationale vivait assez
facilement cette double vie oui va
tricher c'est donné à tout le monde je
pense un certain moment ok tu regardes
vous pourriez avoir de mais qu'en même
temps par exemple j ai fini avec eux les
français au match quand une des choses
que l'on pense de votre moi j'ai
toujours cru qu'en france les gens ont
deux maîtresses c'est normal c'est
normal que mr hamilton en a en fait
normal moi je crois que c'était une
tradition ici ouais c'est aussi une
tradition de fermer sa gueule avec un
autre match
alors on était son signal fort pour moi
c'est un film c'est un film s'appelle le
petit curieux de jean marboeuf voilà
avec qui alors alain bashung en des
affairés le millas margot benjamin boyer
fait y'a pleins monde
christian morin il ya plein plein de
monde et voila voila tu veux regarder ta
caméra et birmanie